c'est une chose qui est assez difficile
mais qui offre certains avantages parce
que ça me permet de travailler avec des
joueurs que je connais très bien puisque
j'ai joué avec le pendant très longtemps
et de connaître un petit peu tous leurs
problèmes les défauts parce que tout le
monde en a et les qualités qu'ils ont
alors essayé de pallier à leurs petits
défauts et d'améliorer grandement leur
qualité je pense que les contacts sont
pour beaucoup plus facile avec des
joueurs que l'on connaît bien qu'avec
des joueurs que l'on a pas l'habitude de
de côtoyer il est certain que parfois
c'est un petit peu gênant parce que on a
tendance à reprocher ou à faire des
petits critiques que l'on pouvait se
faire à soi-même dans tant que joueur
alors ça pose des petits problèmes mais
ce n'est pas très grave
rendez vous n'aviez rabbin que 33 ans
est ce que pendant la saison il ne
viendra pas
l'envy disons de riom filer le maillot
de saint-etienne
mais vous savez ça fait déjà un mois que
l'on a repris l'entraînement et qu'on a
repris une compétition qu'on appelle la
coupe d'été et j'avoue que chaque fois
que je me trouve sur le banc de touche
je suis assez partagé j'ai souvent très
envie de jouer mais enfin nous avons un
effectif assez important je crois qu il
se compose d'une de 16 ou 18 joueurs
et dans ces conditions je ne vois pas
l'opportunité de prendre la place d'un
jeune qui lui a tout son avenir devant
lui
qu il ya beaucoup d
bien renforcé il me semble que le
championnat sera très ouvert je pense à
nice je pense à marseille je pense à
nantes
je pense à reims je pense à au paris
football club
je pense à lyon qui est notre voisin
mais qu'il ne faut pas oublier parce que
lyon a montré l'an dernier qu'il était
capable de rivaliser avec les meilleurs
enfin il ya des équipes qui se tiennent
de très près je crois que le championnat
sera très ouvert et très intéressant